[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه مشاهدينا
الكرام ما اقبح العلمانيين المزعومين
الذين صدعوا رؤوسنا بافكارهم التنويريه
لكن سرعان ما هربوا الى جحورهم الطائفيه
عندما جد الجد ما اقبح ذلك الشويعر
العلمانيه العالم جيه المزعوم الذي ايد
ثوره الخميني لانها تتماشى مع اهوائه
الطائفيه وعارض ثوره الشعب السوري لمجرد
انها لا تتماشى مع عصبيته الطائفيه يضيف
اخر ما اقبح القومجية
[موسيقى]
ذبح صدام في عيد الاضحى المبارك نبدا نقاش
بعد
[موسيقى]
الفاصل اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدينا الكرام
نحن معكم على الهواء مباشره في برنامج
الاتجاه المعاكس هذه الحثالات التي تدافع
عن بشار الاسد ومثل القوميين واليساريين
والليبراليين والعلمانيين تبين انهم الد
اعداء الامه وليسوا من هذه الامه وكل من
يقف ضد ثوره الشعب السوري هو ليس من هذه
الامه بل هو من الد اعدائها فجاءت هذه
الثوره لتمزق الاقنعه ولتك شف الحقائق
وتبين ان هؤلاء ما كانوا الا قوارض يقرضون
الامه هؤلاء تبين انهم خناجر في ظهر الامه
ينحازون كانوا يدعون انهم مع الفقراء ومع
المسحوقين ومع المقهورين ومع الجماهير
الكادحه فتبين انهم معه الظالمين الذين
يقهرون هذه الجماهير ويسحقون كرامه هذه
الجماهير تبين انهم مرتزقه تبين انهم خونه
تبين انهم عملاء
[تصفيق]
وحثالة هم ماذا فيه يشرفهم اعطوني بطلا من
ابطالهم معركه انتصروا فيها الا كلها ضد
الامه مجازر تلو المجازر سوريا 50 عاما
على ايدي هذه الحثالات وهي تذبح والان
يقفون مع الجزار ان من يدافع عن المجرم هو
مجرم مثله ان من يدافع عن القاتل هو قاتل
مثله هؤلاء يثورون لمومس لو مست بكلمه
يقيمون الدنيا ولا يقعدون ويقول حقوق
الانسان واعتداء على الحريه واذا مس محمد
صلى الله عليه وسلم و مس ذات الالهيه
يقولون ويثور اذا مس ويقولون هذه حريه
تعبير وحقوق انسان هؤلاء ليسوا من امتنا
يقولون ان هؤلاء القومجية
لسنا مع طغات ولم نكن في اي يوم من مع
الطغات كنا مع الحريه كنا مع الديمقراطيه
كنا مع التنوير كنا مع تحرير الاوطان اي
قوميه هذه قوميتهم افلست ذبحتنا اذلت سحقت
صنعت لنا الكوارث صنعت لنا الهزائم عندما
كانت انتم صناعه الصهيونيه
العالميه علمانيين طيب بدي اسالك انا ه
السؤال انت هل تؤيد الطاغيه بشار الاسد
ولا تؤيد الاخوان المسلمين انا لا اؤيد
الاخوان المسلمين على الاطلاق الاسد ولا
الاخوان المسلمين الاسد مليون مره ولا
الاخوان المسلمين انت مع الطغات لا ماني
مع الط يا اخي الاخوان بده يقتلوني هل بقي
شيء لم
يحرمه الطواغيت
العسكريون العلمني ولا بس ب شرب بس دقيقه
يا اخي بس انا بدي اسالك بدي اسالك انتم
مشكلتكم بدكم جنس وبدكم تشربوا يا اخي رح
نخليكم تشربوا مين قال لك يا اخي مين قال
لك انت مين قال لك العلمانيه جنس وسكر مين
قال لك العلمانيه جنس سكر شو هال التقزيم
للفكر
العلماني انت تعلم ان النظام السوري يعني
معبوده ومعشوقه الحديث عن المؤامره كل
الدنيا متامر عليه عطارد متامر عليه
المشتري متامر المريخ متامر كل الدنيا
متامر عليه من 50 سنه بيضحك على الشعب
بهذه المؤامره الان موضوع المؤامره اصبح
مهزله مسخره السوريون يضحكون على النظام
وعلى اعلام النظام وعلى ه الكلام الفارغ
86% يقولون لا مؤامره ولا ضرب السخن هذه
ثوره عظيمه كيف ترب اولا اي يعني انا
ساذهب ابعد من ذلك بكثير وساقول انها
مؤامرات جميل وليست مؤامره مؤامرات خرجت
من من دول
و ب يعني بامور
اقتصاديه باضعاف سوريا باركا سوريا قائد
المؤامره هو بشار الاسد الذي وصفته صحيفه
هارتس بملك ملوك اسرائيل في
2011 بعد 15 ي ينفذ مخططا صهيونيا في
سوريا بشار الاسد يخطط مخططا
صهيونيا اصبح هيسم المناع مخبر يعني حقوقي
حقوق انت
المخبر
عملت وت واختل واموالك معوز عليها في
سوريا واذا ولكن
تريد
المحجو من السفاره امك تبرت منك لا لا لا
عيبر تدخل في امي امك تبرت منك هو اللي حك
اسمع اسمع امي قالت لي قبل هذا البرنامج
سامسك لك صوره ياسين من اول البرنامج الى
اخره احد الاخوه المشاركين في فيسبوك يقول
لك اهو ثمن الانتصار على هذه المؤامره
تدمير مليون منزل اهو تشريد مليونين ونصف
المليون
انسان هل هو هل هل الثمن 300000 لاجئ هل
الثمن اعتقال 250,000 سوري هل الثمن قتل
50,000 سوري 100000 معاق انهيار العلاقه
بين اطياف المجتمع السوري قتل السوري
لاخيه السوري طيب يا سيدي طيب شو استفدنا
نحن من تدبير هال المؤامره اذا دمرنا
سوريا كلها معها يعني نحن مثل ما بقولوا
يعني رمينا رمينا دك دكتور انا عم بحسب
اللي حكيته ويعني هناك 18 مليون سوري حسب
ارقامك اي ماذا
الدوله لا لا ما في بلاهم لا لا سناتي الى
الى اللاجئين
اللاجئين لاجئ ما له قيمه اللاجئين ذهبوا
الى المناطق الامنه تحت حمايه الدوله في
سوريا لم يحدث في التاريخ الحديث ولا
القديم ان اعطي ضوء اخضر لنظام ليبيد شعبه
بالطائرات والدبابات ومختلف انواع الاسلحه
كما اعطي للنظام السوري ما نحن على الارض
عم نشوف من الذي تدخل لحمايه الشعب السوري
اذا في مؤامره اذا في اذا النظام محمي
لديه ضوء اخضر من يا دكتور من العالم يا
اخي بتسالك المسؤولين السوريين المسؤولين
الس السوريين تسالهم في الاعلام السوري
يقولون المتام الامبرياليه اسرائيل المتام
كذا كذا كذا وفي جلساتهم الخاصه يقولون
نحن لسنا خائفين لانه امريكا مش عاوزه
تشيلنا هكذا يقولون ثانيا اذا كانت
اسرائيل ضد النظام اذا كانت اسرائيل ضد
النظام السوري اذا كانت اليست هذه افضل
فرصه تاريخيه لاسرائيل لتتخلص من هذا
النظام وهو يواجه شعبا باكمله بشوي بتشيله
لماذا تحميه لماذا حدود سوريا مع اسرائيل
هي الاهدا كل الحدود مفتوحه الا الحدود
الاسرائيليه تحميها اسرائيل طبني هذه
معادله تختلف المعادله انه بعد خروج مصر
وتوقيع كام ديفيد
وذهب كل هؤلاء العرب او معظم العرب
وارتموا بحضن امريكا خليني اقول انه في
مؤامره انا بدي اتفق انه معك في مؤامره
بقع بالمؤامره مؤامرات
بعمف هذه المؤامرات عمف كل عاين اسرائيل
كل اللي بد اه بسوريا نفذوا النظام دمر
البلد اسرائيل بدها ال سنه لتدمر اللي دمر
النظام الان هي وامريكا البيادق السوريه
يعني من هو الذي ينفذ على
الارض طالبه الشعب السوري ومعظم الشعب
السوري بالحسب للامان والاستقرار كم فرع
هناك للمركز للبنك المركزي السوري في
سوريا كم فرع دمشق
وحلب استحدثوا فرعا جديدا للبنك المركزي
السوري قبل فتره في اللاذقيه في الساحل
ليش بربك ليش انتقلت ليش انتقلت الاسلحه
الكيماويه الى الساحل تطور تطور هذا اليس
هذا هو التامر بعينه على تقسيم البلد على
ت تذبح البلد لا يوجد تقسيم ولا يوجد اي
شيء خاد هور من من الفيسبوك يقول لك نعم
مؤامره ضد نظام ضد نظام الرئيس لانه كان
اعدل واحسن نظام بالك كله مو حرامي مو
حرامي ولا خلى الاقتصاد بيد قرايبه ولا
عننا سجون ولا معتقلين نهائيا والجامعات
الاولى الجامعات السوريه الاولى على
العالم والخبز ما في طوابير وما عننا
بطاله ولا خريجين الجامعات اكبر حلمهم
يطلعوا فيزا ويروحوا على الخليج ولا عننا
اعتقال تحسف ولا تعذيب والجيش بصلي وبصوم
وبزك كمان فعلا مؤامره يا رجل هناك الف
سبب وسبب كي يثور السوريون الف سبب يعني
اذا اذا اذا قلت لي ان هذه ثوره فهي افشل
ثوره في التاريخ حتى
انتفاضه مقاوم بالثرثره يصيح احمد مطر
ممانع
بالثرثره له لسان مدع يصول في شوارع الشام
كسيف عنتره يكاد يلتف على الجولان
والقنيطرة
[موسيقى]
صح من نومه وصاح في رجاله مؤامره مؤامره
واعلن الحرب على الشعب وكان رده على
الكلام مزر محور مقاومه الممانعه لو اردنا
تعريفه هو ليس الا بمحور عهر ودعاره عهر
ودعاره نعم وجبهه الصمود والتصدي هي ليست
الا جبهه فجور وبغي فما المقاومه في عرف
هذا النظام الا مقاومه لاراده الحياه وما
ممانعه الا ممانعه للحريه والكرامه ممانعه
بعد انفاسنا بمراقبه احلامنا ونحن نيام
انت ان كنت سوريا فعليك حتى اثناء حلمك ان
رايت الاسد ان تمجده ان تمجده كانه القائد
الخالد كانه الاله الواحد الاوحد وهب
الحياه والموت واياك ثم اياك ان لم تفعل
ذلك حتى في نومك هذا النظام دعم المقاومه
في كل مكان دعم المقاومه الفلسطينيه دعم
المقاومه اللبنانيه انتصار وانسحاب
اسرائيل من جنوب لبنان وانسحاب اسرائيل
وهزيمه اسرائيل في تموز 2006 دليل على
انتصار
المقاومه هل تعتقد ان بشار الاسد يطبق
شعار الاسد او نحرق البلد صوت على صفحه
الاتجاه المعاكس
25127 نعم
94.9 لا 5.1 شريف شحاده لو بدات معك في
واقع الامر عندما طرحت هذا السؤال على
التصويت جاءني الكثير من الردود الغاضبه
يقولون كيف تقول ان الاسد يحرق البلد
حرقها وانتهت العمليه لم يبقى شيء لم
يحرقه كيف ترد اولا هذا التصويت مردود على
مش هذا التصويت ما بدي انا بعرف دائما هو
اهم تصويت اللي بتصوت فيه المخابرات بيكون
صحيح هذا التصويت مردود نحن صوتنا بالامس
في قناه الدنيا طلع معنا 95% يؤيدون الاسد
في طريقه التعامل مع المجمو في طريقه
التعامل مع المجموعات الارهابيه الموجوده
والتي بثتها كل مح العالم طيب تقول لي
الذي حرق سوريا هم المغول الجدد المتامرون
على سوريا نعم العصابات المسلحه نعم كل
هؤلاء الارهابيون السلفيون الوهابيون
والعرعور اللي بدك اياهم ماشي انا اتفق
معك او سات فق معك جدلا او لنفترض جدلا ان
كل الدمار الذي حدث في سوريا على ايدي
هؤلاء هم فعلوه فعلا دمروا حلب ودمروا حمص
ودمروا درعه ودمروا ريف دمشق ودمروا كل
سوريا طيب الا يخجل بشار الاسد ان يبقى في
الحكم اذا لم يستطع حمايه سوريا من هؤلاء
الذين دمروا البلد عليه وعلى البلد بدي
اسالك سؤال بدي اسالك اليس من حق الشعب
السوري الان ان يطلب من هذا الرئيس ان
يتنحى لانه لم يستطع حمايه البلد مش لانه
دمر البلد مطلوب بقاء الرئيس الاسد لانه
ضح البلد يا خليني احكي يا دكتور لانه
ضمانه وحده الاراضي السوريه اليس من حق
الشعب السور
ان يقول لبشار الاسد للرئيس السوري يا
سيدي انت لا تصلح للحكم لان البلد دمر من
قبل العصبات الارهابيه يعني الاس مشكلتكم
انتم بسوريا كمان يقول من يصنع الاشباح
تظهر له انتم صنعتم الاشباح فطلعت لكم
ودمرت البلد طيب اول شي طيب يا اخي اذا
رئيس مش قادر يحمي البلد البلد ادمرت شو
قاعد عم يسوي قل لي انا انا سوري مش من
حقي يقول له ليش تخلي هال العصابات
المسلحه بنت ال 60 الف شو اسمه دمر البلد
طول بالك ليش دمرت اولا هذا تمرد عسكري
مسلح من كل دول المنطقه اتت الى سوريا انت
بتعرف وانا بعرف انه هذه الهجمه على سوريا
لا تقول لي اصلاح تعز الله لانه ما ماد
طايقين بس دقيقه بدي يحكي اثنين عندما
واجهت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه نفس
الهجمه عليها جورج بش احتل دولتين
افغانستان والعراق وقتل في العراق 4
ملايين اليوم سوريا تدافع عن وحده التراب
بس بس بس يا سيد شريف سانتقل صحيح جورج
بوش عندما تعرضت بلده للعمل الارهابي دمر
العراق ودمر افغانستان ما دمر امريكا مثل
ما عم بيوي بشار الاسد دمر سوريا يا زلمه
نحن نحمي سوريا ولولا ان كان الرئيس الاسد
حريصا على وحده سوريا وعلى امن سوريا
لوجدت ان المنطقه قد قسمت وقسمت سوريا
قالوا لنا اما الولد او في بلاد الشام لن
يبقى احد قالوا لنا اما الولد او ان قطعان
المجوس الفرس تحتل البلد قلنا لهم بئس
الولد ووالد د ومن ولد وفاسد ومن فسد بل
بئس من يحسب ان الجحش والوحش اسد من قال
ان القرد والقراد قد امسى اسد لم ننسى ما
فعل الطغاه المجرمون ومن جحد لما استباحوا
حمص او ادلب او درع البلد لما استباحوا
مسجدا ومن سجد لما احتمى ال نبيح بالشبيحة
زف الرحيل فودعوا هذا البلد فشام للاحرار
للثوار حاضنه ولمن صمد ضحك الولد عبس
الولد خاب الولد سقط الولد ووالد وما ولد
يقولون بالحرف الواحد ان بشار الاسد او
الرئيس بشار الاسد هو من اكثر الطواغيت
تكلفه عبر التاريخ لم يحدث في التاريخ ان
تم تدمير شعب ذبح شعب وتدمير بلد من اجل
عائله برب
هذا الشعب السوري العظيم وهذا البلد
العظيم طيب معقول نبيعه مشان بشار الاسد
ومخلوف وشيش وشويه بيلفوا حولهم يا رجل
هذه سوريا هذه سوريا اكبر من الاسد وابو
الاسد يقول لك مو هيك انا بدي
اسكنا انا بدي اقوللك شو بقولنا هول جماع
اناك شو اولا لا استطيع ان ارى هذه الهجمه
بضخامتها وقوتها انها هجمه من اجل الاصلاح
طيب هل سمعت
بقصه سيدتين التين جتا الى النبي سليمان
كانتا متنازعين على طفل ماشي فجاؤوا للنبي
سليمان قالوا وحده تقول هذا الولد ي
والثاني تقول هذا الولد الي فقال النبي
سليمان انا راح احل لكم القصه اعطوني
هالولد رح اقطعه بالنص انت بتاخذي نص وهذه
بتاخذ نص فال الام احداهم قالت لا لا لالا
خليها تاخذه الثاني لانه عند الامومه طيب
اذا كان عند بشار الاسد وطنيه ليش ما يسلم
سوريا بدل ما يقطعها اربا اربا ليش ما
يتعلم من يتعلم النبي سليمان لا لا لا
لحظه لابي سطع البلد لو انه وطني هل بدي
اسالك دقيقه هل هناك حاكم وطني حاكم وطني
بدمر حلب وبيدمر حمص وبيدمر بدي اسالك هل
يعقل انه 7 ملايين سوري الان ياكلون من
الزباله مشان يخليه ص الاسد يا زلم يا رجل
اسمع شوي لا تغيروا التاريخ حرفتم التاريخ
والان تريدون ان تحرفه على قال فلان وقال
علتان لولا الرئيس الاسد لوجدت 50 محافظه
في سوريا و50 طائفه بس عندي 7 ملايين مشر
يوجد في سوريا مشردين من هؤلاء الذين
يدخلون الى
البيوت ليش ما يحميهم جيش الحمت الدمار
الديار طول بالك هذا الجيش نوجه له التحيه
عبر هذه القناه لانه جيش وطني بامتياز
ولولا هذا الجيش الوطني لقسمت رفعه الاسد
في احد المؤتمرات مؤتمرات القطريه المؤتمر
القطري يقول بالحرف الواحد مبررا اجتياح
حماه وتدمير حماه يقول استالين ضحى ب 10
ملايين للمحافظه على الثوره البلشفيه ونحن
مستعدون لتقليد تلك العمليه الجراحيه يعني
قبل 20 سنه كان النظام يرفع شعار اباده
سوريا بالامس القريب الرئيس السوري بشار
الاسد ردد نفس الكلام وصف عمليه تدمير
سوريا وذبح الشعب السوري بعمليه جراحيه
يعني صور تشريد 7 ملايين وتدمير المدن على
رؤوس اصحابها بدي اسالك الطائرات السوريه
متى ا ارت الطائرات السوريه على هدف
اسرائيلي في تاريخها نعم لم تغر الان
بطولات السوري بطولات الطيارين السوريين
وال والاوكرانيين والروس والايرانيين لا
نراها الا من خلال البراميل اللي اشتعل
البرميل مصنع البراميل اللي اشتعل بجبلي
من مده كم يوم يا رجل هل يعقل نظام يسقط
براميل مليانه بكل انواع المتفجرات على
ناس بدي اسالك اللواء شريف المقت الطيار
قال نحن كطيار قال نحن كنا ممنوعين
الطائرات السوريه كانت ممنوعه ان تمر فوق
المدن والقرى الاهله بالسكان لماذا لانهم
يخافون على النساء الحامل الحوامل ويخفون
على الاطفال يقول لك الان دقيقه يقول لك
المقت يقول لك الان هذه الطائرات لم تترك
مدينه او كذا الا ما دمرتها عن بكره ابيها
انت رحت على حرستا رحت على دوه بدي اسالك
شو كتب شو كتبوا الشبيحه في دريا ذبحناه
من اجل عيونك يا اسد وك يا زلمه روق رو لا
تعصب بدي اعطيك سكره مشان اطيني سكره منان
ربكك ما يعطيك
سكره دير بالك لا يكون حاي لانه عم زع
مخدرات دقيقه بس دقيقه شو يعني شو كيف
دقيقه ما بد شيء بصراحه النظام
حاليا يوزع حبوب هالوس على العساكر شي
الثاني السجناء يا شريف اش حاده يحقنون
بالايدز في سوريا الادز السيده يا دكتور ل
دكتور يا دكتور يا دكتور فيصل يا دكتور
فيصل اذا البوسي طلع سيء وحسون طلع سيء
فشو ما حكى زدت و ور الم يقل الرئيس الاسد
نقل عن الرئيس الاسد نقل عن الرئيس الاسد
حرفيا بالحرف الواحد قال لمستمعي ان ال
الاسد سيعيدون سوريا الى اهلها كما
استلموها قبل 40 سنه اي ان الرئيس السوري
جاهز تماما كي يدمر ما انجز خلال عهد تولي
ال الاسد الحكم في سوريا بخيتان قال لنواف
البشير وبامكانك تساله قال له حبيبي اذا
مفكرين ال الاسد يسلمو سوريا مستعدين
يقتلوا 10 مليون سوري ولا بدي اسال انا
الان لا بصدق لا هذا ولا هذا انا بصدق
اللي عم صير على الارض خلينا دمرت البلد
ولا لاق شوي انت قلت قالوا وانا راح اقول
لك انت قلت قالوا بلا ما تجيب السند قالوا
ويقول
ويقولون لا انا رح اقولك انا عم اقول يقول
فلان لو الاسد اليوم انت كان معك بابور
درزي وانا معي بسبور سني والثاني معه
باسبور
علوي كانكور علوي الر الاس كان معك باسبور
علوي مش السني تمام هذا العالم لا يريد
بشار الاسد لانه يمثل مشروع كما مثله عبد
الناصر وكما مثله تيتو وكما مثله غاندي
بشرفك تقارن بشار بعبد الناصر
واقوى سيدي اقوى الف مره
سور عندما يبدا هذا النظام بالانهيار ان
اول الناس الذي سيهجمون على الضريح المقدس
في القرداحه هم العلويون واهل القرداحه
اليس هناك مبالغه وساق بنفسي كيف والله
ساقو مع رجالي وسادو على قبر حافظ الاسد
هو اسوا بكثير من من كوهين الذي جاء يتجسس
لصالح اسرائيل لو قاتل اليهود وقتلهم
والله لامنت به اطلب الي ان يستنكر القصف
المدفعي والهليكوبتر والدبابات للشعب
اينما وجد ولتكن هناك وسائل الخراطين وسا
الاق استنكر واطالب ان يتم القصف المدفعي
والصاروخي على كل واحد بيحمل سلاح ضد
بلده هال المجموعات المسلحه دخلت لكل
منطقه بالشام دخ دخلت لكل منطقه بسوريا
وشو صار بالنهايه صار انسحاب تكتيكي تك تك
تك تكتيكي طلعوا حملوا حالهم ومشوا خربوا
الدنيا وحملوا حالهم مشيوا فلتحب قبري
عميقا فلتحب قبري عميقا وادفنوني واقفا
حتى اظل اصيح بين الناس لا تحنوا الجباه
موتوا وقوفا لا تموتوا تحت اقدام الطغات
منين بده يعلمي منين بده يعلم لي الاطفال
والجامعات وال كذا من اسطنبول ومن باريس
ليش طلعت حضرتك من
الخالديه ماقدر تمسح الارض م اشكالي الناس
درج مدمره ام حلب على وشك الدمار ادلب
مدمره درعه مدمره ريف دمشق مدمر كل هذه
دمرته العصابات المسلحه ماشي العصابات
المسلحه اذا هذه اكبر هزيمه في جبهه
النظام بتاعك دقيقه يا اخي من جهه يوم
بقول لكم انتم دمرتوا سوريا بتقولوا ان
العصابات المسلحه يوم بقول لكم العصابات
المسلحه دمرت وهزمت ما بتعرفوا تجاوبوا
جاوبني على هذا الكلام يعني يا دكتور بدي
اسالك اليس من حق السوريين ان يسالوا اذا
هذا النظام سمح للعصابات الم ان تدمر حمص
وريف دمشق وحلب وادلب ودرعا وكل البلد شو
قاعد يسوي هذا النظام كيف بده يحمينا من
اسرائيل اذا كم واحد شلعوط جابوه شرق
الذريات ممكن لا لا لا هم هم مو بس اصابات
مسلحه مدفوعه بدول مدفوعه يا اخي مدفوعه
من الشيطان الرجيم طبعا
د ممره على سوريا وانا كنت معك بحلقه
المؤامره اشتغلت فيها دكتور كلهم اشتغل
الولايات المتحده فرنسا بريطانيا
ض ماشي طيب لعن ابو هال الجيش ولا لا لا
لا لا ما
لعن شوف را احكيلك شغله يا دكتور معظم
الجيش السوري في سكناته الجيش السوري
تفاجا بعمليات هي فممكن تجهيز فر لتعامل
جابني جابني ه هناك سوريا تدمرت كلها
لماذا ل ي حت ال سوريا ما تدمرت هذا كلام
هذا كلام حجاب وغيره حجابه بلك صدقك انت
اللي جاي من لندن وما تصدق رئيس الوزراء
اللي جاي من سوريا حجاب وين كان عم يفتل
بدار الزور وبحسك وبيه وبدر كان عم يفتل
قبل ما يطلع من هناك بكل البلاد ومعه
الامن تبعه ومعه الشرطه تبعه ما شاف مدمر
كان عم يطلع يحكي مع العالم كله كان عم
يطلع يحكي مع الناس كلها ما خلى مدينه
بسوريا ما فتل عليها بعدين بطل طلع من هون
بقول سوريا 70% تحت ايد الجيش ما يسمى حر
ولا غيره بدي اسالك انت هل تتجرا ان تسافر
من الساحل السوري الى دمشق وليش لا ما في
كانك فحل وروح روح كانك بالطياره لانه شاش
الحر مسيطر عن كل المنطقه يا سيدي روح ك
زلمه روح يطلع زلح يطلع حواجز طا يا سيدي
انا عم بتصل على الساحل يقولوا لي اذا
اردت ان تاتي من الساحل الى دمشق بدك خمسه
اشهر تنتظر تاتي
بالطائره في مجرمين يا دكتور على الطريق
وين ح عن وين مخابرات عن وين مخابرات سيوا
البلد ا سيطروا راح يسيطروا على البلد عم
يتعاملوا اسمع يا دكتور شو كانوا يقولوا
كانوا يقولوا الحصم العسكري اليوم علاج
امني يا سيدي الشبيحه يفعلون فعلهم في كل
المدن والقرى السوريه بالامس دخلوا جديده
عرطوز لم يتركوا محل الا نهبوه الشبيحه
وكسروه والناس لا تستطيع ان تنظر حتى من
الشبابيك وين بطوله هال الجيش الحر بدي
اسالك انظر الى دمشق في دمشق يدوسون على
راس الرجال والنساء والاطفال الحواجز كل
واحد عامل زلمه على على الحواجز وين
هالجيان الحر ما شفنا ولا عمليه انتحاريه
ولا استشهاديه يدوسون على اهل دمشق
كلياتهم ومثل الجردان قاعدين بره وينكم
انتم اربع اربع ثوار دخلوا لمبنى هيئه
الاركان احتلوا الطوابق الثلاثه هذا
مركزك مركز هذا مركز سيادي للنظام في دمشق
اربعه دخلوا احتلوا ثلاث طوابق وقتلوا من
الشبيحه بعدد شعر راس هال الشبيح الصغير
اللي جايب هدول راح ينتهوا عمليات نوعيه
نازلين فيهم صاروا هلا باطراف ح بقول لك
سيف الدوله يا دكتور بول لك سيف الدوله ق
بقول لك سيف الدوله بقول لك باب نسالك
سؤال ايمت حينه ايمت ينتهوا انتم قلتوا
لنا انه ينتهوا بعد بالاسبوع الثاني من
الثوره قلعوا اللبنانيين ققول لك خلصت
فاللي خلص باخر النهار الزوط والاكل في
سوريا فقط قلتلك اسبوع وا دكتور
المره الماضي ست اهر ما في سلاح خليهم
يعتمدوا على شي شغله ماشي عندما يلجا
النظام الى سلاح الطيران ويلجا الى
الاسلحه المحرمه دوليا كالقناع العنقوديه
التي تحدثت عنها كل منظمات حقوق الانسان
وعندما يلجا الى القنابل الفراغيه يقول لك
وزير الخارجيه الفرنسي كلما استشر النظام
هذا دليل انه فقد السيطره يعني يقاتل
بطريقه جبانه وهناك مثل يقول احذر ضربه
الجبان هذا الضرب اللي عم بقول فيه النظام
دليل ياس دليل جبن دليل انه منسحق دليل
انه منسحق انا عم بعطيك شو عم بقوله رد
علي بدون اولا الكلام القصص اللي حكاها عن
المنطقه الفلانيه والمنطقه الفلانيه هذا
كلام المعلق تبعكم لعميد صفوت الزيا هناك
من يقول ان هناك اتفاقا الان لا تسال
سوريا يا اخي انا بعطيك وانت قل لي انا
والله لا الي بالنفير ولا بالعير ولا
بالعير ولا بالنفير مثل ما بقولها ماشي
انا عم بسالك السوريون يقولون الان انه
هناك اتف ا بين النظام
السوري يا اخي دقيقه دقيقه هناك اتفاق بين
النظام السوري واسرائيل هدفه تدمير سوريا
وكل الذي حصل الان بدي اسالك من المستفيد
الاول من كل هذا الدمار في سوريا وانهاك
الجيش السوري اليس
اس
اسرائ دتور اسمي اسمع ما يقول له الثوار
يا د صاح البطه هدنه هدنه ارجوكم اعطوني
الحقنه فرجالي لم يبقى من
فو افلست واع المني خه ايا كي تصل الى جيش
الشحنه اما الثوار فقد رفضوا ان يعطوا
للقاده ل هدنه صاحوا صاحوا والصوت له وجل
يا بشار لقصرك جئنا وصبرك يا بشار صبرك
احنا ودنا نحفر قبرك صبرك يا المحتل
الخاسي تران جايين لقصرك هذا النظام
المقاوم الممانع الاسد
الله بتطلع بتطلع صوص انت انت
والك بدكون كيس جم فيصلي
حمكن هناك تحالف بين فاسدين من الاسره
الحاكمه وتجار فساد يريدون الاستحواذ على
ثرت الكويت هذا عمق الازمه نحن جياع كرامه
جياع كرامه وليس يعني الكويت مو ناقصنا
احنا امور ماديه ولا احنا نبحث عن لقمه
عيش الحمد لله الامور من احسن ما يكون لكن
هناك اهينت كرامات
تم ضربنا بالقنابل والغاز وغيرها تم اهانه
الكويتيين وطوائفهم وقبائلهم وكل فئاتهم
الاجتماعيه عبر سلسله من التحريض المستمر
من شله منحطه سافله للاسف تحيط بمتن فيذ
في الاسره وفي السلطه تحيط بهم ويرعون
ويغذيه ويدفعون لهم المال ناس مرتشين
منحطين من اسو ما يكون خلقا واخلاقا وهم
الكيت لا هذه ادوات هذه ادوات يغذون تجار
الفساد والفاسدون من الاسره الحاكمه كل
الانظمه العربيه التي تنتفض ضد شعوبها
تتهم المنتفضين والمتظاهرين والمحتجين
والمعارضين بانهم وهميين وكذا وانظر ما
حصل في سوريا لماذا لا تتعلمون الدرس ادخل
لي بالموضوع فورا لماذا لا تتعلمون الدرس
لماذا لا تصلحون في وقت الاصلاح لماذا
تلجوا الى الاستبداد في وقت الاصلاح
والثورات هذا هو السؤال منذ متى كان
استخدام الصلاحيات الدستوريه لامير البلاد
عبر قوانين وقواعد ملزمه استبدادا هذا
الدستور اليوم اعطى للامير بسلطه منفرده
حق خالص له بان يعدل ما يراه في قضيه
مرسوم الضروره ماذا نفهم عندما يقول امير
البلاد نحن اجرينا كل هذه التعديلات من
اجل حمايه الوحده الوطنيه ماذا نفهم بهذه
الوحده الوطنيه يعني الا يمل الحكام العرب
من المتاجره بمروج الوحده الوطنيه كل واحد
بيطلع لي بيقول لي بدي احمي الوحده
الوطنيه بشار الاسد طلع بده يحمي الو
الوحده الوطنيه ما ظل سوريين بحبوا بعض
راحت البلد ب 6 ال داهيه الى متى المتاجره
بالوحده الوطنيه فهمني بالله شو الوحده
الوطنيه عندكم كلام صاحب صاحب السمو لا
يتاجر بالوحده الوطنيه هؤلاء حكام فاسدين
كيف تحمي الوطن الوحده الوطنيه بانزال
الجيش وبانزال كل قوات الامن الى البلد
وشل الحياه وضرب الناس ودوس الناس والبعض
يتحدث عن مرتزقه عن بلطجيه عن شبيحه
مستوردين من الاردن وغير الاردن لقتل
الشعب الكويتي ماذا تقول لهم رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني كاميرون في المظاهرات التي حصلت
في بريطانيا عندما قال عندما يصل مساله
للامن الوطني لا مجال الحديث عن اي امر
اخر لازم نعرف منو هذا الرجل لان بالعراق
حقيقه دكتور لا يوجد دوله ولا توجد حكومه
ولا يوجد جيش ولا يوجد اقتصاد وانما يوجد
شخص اسمه نوري كامل العلي نوري كامل العلي
لازم نرف العلي وليس المالكي انا لازم
نعرف من هذا الرجل نوري كامل العلي هو
رئيس الوزراء هذا الرجل مسقط راسه في
منطقه قريه جلاجل في محافظه كربلاء اللي
منطقه سده الهنديه حاليا بطوج وهذا هذا
الرجل ينتمي اصوله الى قبيله القريضات
وقبيله القريضات هي نسبها يرجع الى قبيله
بنو قريضه اليهوديه التي نزحت من الحجاز
الى الموصل وفي الموصل تشيعت في نهايه
الدوله العثمانيه في بدايه العشرينات من
القرن الماضي يعني يهودي المالكي اصلا
يهودي من بني قريضه وهذا الرجل نزل مع
عائلته الى كربلاء واليوم يحكم العراق
وهذا الكلام يعني مثبت
بدليل الكاتب العراقي ياسر عبد الرحمن
عباس الحيدري في كتاب الديمقراط طائفيه في
في حكم العراق ياكد نسب اصول رئيس الوزراء
العراقي الحالي هو من بني قريضه اليهوديه
العراقيين عايشين انت قلت بالمقدمه على
بحر من النفط محيط من النفط انت تقول ما
عندهم كرامتهم جلاص ماي ما عند العراقي
ماي عذب ما عند العراق يشرب ماي حتى تروح
هذه المليارات الى جيوب الفاسدين وتمول
عمليات القتل المنظم في سوريا هذه
المليارات يا رجل ميزانيه العراق 84 مليار
دولار العام الماضي والسنه جاوزنا ال 100
والعراق اليوم ما عنده حتى البطاقه
التموينيه لغاها دمر العراقيين لا في اكل
لا في شرب لا في تعليم لا في تدريس لا في
صحه ومن العدل تحميل المالكي كل هذه لان
هنالك بعض الاشخاص يريدون استغلال كل
الظروف لاسقاط المالكي ليس لاصلاح العراق
وانما لخصومه مع المالك فقط جم جميل
فلوسنا جاي تروح لقتل اهلنا وليس الشعب
السوري اهنا السوريين لقتلهم بالعتاد
والمال والنفط وحرمان العراقيين من ابسط
حقوق الانسان الماء والكهرباء والدواء
والتعليم كل هذه
انتهت اريد ان يعني اواجهك ايضا بكلام
لاحد قاده حماس القساميين براء نزار ريان
وهو ابن القائد القسامي الشهير يقول
بالحرف الواحد على صفحتي بالفيسبوك وردني
ان النظام السوري المجرم يتفاخر بصواريخ
القسام ويتاجر بها على شعبه ايها السفاحون
الاوغاد من يقتحم منازل قاده حماس
ومكاتبهم في دمشق ويغلقها بالشمع الاحمر
لا يحق له التفاخر بصواريخها يا حسن نصر
الله لا تتمسح بغزه وتدافع عن نظام الاسد
المجرم فاقد الشرعيه الخسام اخزاك يا نصر
الله وفضحك واعلن ان صواريخه محليه اسم
الصاروخ ام 75 ام رمز للشهيد و75 هي مدى
الصاروخ هذا شخص من كذا لا تتاجرون يقول
لك كفاكم متاجره بهم متاجره و ممانعه
ومقاومه الفلسطينيون يقتلون الان هناك
بقول لك دقيقه في الوقت الذي تقصف فيه
اسرائيل قطاع غزه انتم تقصف المخيمات
الفلسطينيه في مخيم اليرموك والتضامن بدي
اسالك ظل في فلسطيني ما مات بمخيم اليرموك
يا زلم شو بتختلف عن
اسرائيل لظه لحظه اولا ما تدعيه من ق قيام
القوات السوريه بقصف مخيم هذا ادعاء باطل
لا اساس له من الصحه المخيم موجود وكل يوم
يتم تصوير المخيم وينقل المجموعات
الارهابيه قامت بقصف الهوي من اجل تحريك
المخيم المخيمات الفلسطينيه تقصف وتشرد
ويعتقل ابناؤها ويختفي ابناؤها ويدخلها
الشبيحه وحطوا شيء جديد سموه لجان الشعبيه
هذا ما يريدونه من حماس ان تتحول الى فصيل
شبيح كحمد جبريل يريدون لهم ان يقفوا معهم
في قتل الشعب السوري الشعب الين ل ينقلب
على الشعب السوري الشعب الفلسطيني انحاز
للحق وللحريه وللشعب السوري الشعب
الفلسطيني لا يمكن ان يخذل الشعب السوري
لا يمكن ان يقف معه نظام مجرم يمثله هذا
المجرم ايضا ان ربنا سبحانه وتعالى زاد
هؤلاء المقاومين في فلسطين نصرا فوق نصر
عندما فكوا الارتباط مع هذا النظام المجرم
زادهم عزه فوق عزه ومنع عندما انحازوا
للشعب السوري ضد النظام المج انت حاقد
وطائفي انتم كنتم تريدون من حماس ومن
الفصائل الفلسطينيه الاخرى ان تشارككم في
ذبح السوريين والفلسطينيين ردا على ما
يسمى بالمؤامره كونيا نعم حماس وهؤلاء
هؤلاء لا يمكن ان يقتلوا اخوتهم
الفلسطينيين والسوريين كما فعل كما قال لك
جبريل الذي تحول الى اكبر شبيح هو وجماعته
طيب بدي اسالك احمد جبريل هذا سؤال من
الفلسطينيين هل يعقل ان يقتل الفلسطينيين
والسوريين في سوريا ليش ما بروح لي على
غزه ليش ما بيروح لي على غزه جاي يشبح
بدمشق السوريين على كل حال له يوم عند
السوريين كما يقول السوريين احمد جبريل
الشبيح هذا ابدا اعطيني واحد مسؤول سوري
التقى بخالد مشعل او باي قياده من قيادات
حماس وقال لهم تعالوا قاتلوا قلنا لهم لا
تتدخلوا في الشان الداخلي السوري وعليكم
الالتفات الى مشروعكم الوطني التحرري
الجمعه الماضيه الجمعه الماضيه قتل 29
واحد استشر 29 واحد في غزه كم واحد سقطوا
في سوريا 114 هذا بدك تقارن لو قارنا بين
بين بين بين شارون نتنياهو وبشار الاسد
قارنا بينهم لحظه من يكون اكثر اجراما هذا
السؤال بقول للمشاهدين من الذي يقتل شعبه
50 ال قتيل وشهيد وجريح ومفقود بمئات
الالاف صاروا الان و 30% من البلد مدمر هل
هذا هو المقاوم الذي يقدم فلسطين يلعن
ابوها فلسطين اذا كان تملها الدم السوري
اه ما شاء الله والله
بالله مناضل مناضل ره خ خلي تتحرر فل يقول
لك بعض الفلسطينيين على الاقل
نحن تقصفه تقصفه في غزه دقيقه سواريخ ذكيه
اما براميل في سوريا فهي براميل غبيه لو
قارنا عدد الذين قتلوا هذا بنقول لك سؤاله
عدد الذين قتلتهم اسرائيل من الفلسطينيين
على مدى تاريخها وفي الايام الماضيه قتلت
اسرائيل اليوم 10 15 بنفس اليوم النظام
يقتل 200 سوري 300 سوري طيب بدي اسالك ما
بتخجل يا
زلمه ما بتخجل توا على اسرائيل لا لا لا
السوريين الذين يقتلون بالامس ادخلت تركيا
2600 رجل من من تنظيم القاعده الى منطقه
راس العين شو يعني بوقف مكتوفين الايدي
وسوريا تحترق طيب جميل تحترق منوقف مكتوفي
الايدي من يقتل الان هم من تنظيم القاعده
على شاكله الشب هون الشب الاسمر على شاكله
حمزه الخطيب من حزه الخطيب ب يدلي الملوح
اللي كان عمره 16
سنه شهيد من الجيش قتل وانت الان تدافع عن
الجيش 100 ال من الشهداء من الجيش ق اكر
جز الشكر 100 ال شهيد من الجيش الجيش
السوري خسر 100000 اي نعم هذه نقولها
لمشاهدين نقولها المشاهدين
باسلحتهم اليش ما في 2009 عندما اطلقت
صواريخ من داخل لبنان على شمال اسرائيل
قام حزب الله بقياده حسن نصر الله ووصف
الصواريخ التي اطلقت على اسرائيل
بالصواريخ المشبوهه مش كلامي كلامه السؤال
الاخر نصر الله يقول الان هذه المنطقه
ستحرر او سيحرر الاسود والابطال طيب بما
انه ستحرر الاسود والابطال وين حيفا وهيفا
دقيقه بدي اسالك والسؤال الاخر اللي
سالوني اه السوريين كثير كيف تريد منا ان
نصدقك يا حسن نصر الله اذا كان جنودك
يقتلون السوريين في حمص وجاي تقول لي بدي
ادافع عن فلسطين كيف ما هذا المقاوم جي
الذي يقتل في مكان ويدافع في مكان كذب
دليلك كذب دليلك انا اقول هذا الكلام اذا
لم تعطيني عليه دليل واحد دليل واحد فقط
ارني واحد يا سيدي دقيقه دقيقه الذين
يطلبون دليلا على مشاركه حزب الله في قتل
السوريين كالذين يط انه هل الشمس تشرق من
الشرق لا لا دقيقه يا اخي خليني اعطي صوره
طول بالك انت تتحدث عن رجل قاتل اسرائيل
واطلق صو اين صواريخه الان غز تحترق
صواريخ هيفا هيفا وما بعد
هيفا حينما تزعم حماس انها
انتصرت لن اتحدث عن 166 شهيد فلسطيني فضلا
عن اكثر من 1300 جريح لن اتحدث
عنهم مقابل خمسه او ست اسرائيليين يعني
الواحد ب 50 او ب 40 لن اتحدث عن هذا
لانهم عندهم رد جاهز طول الوقت يقول ان
العبره ليست بالعدد وكان الدم الفلسطيني
رخيص الى هذا الحد الدم الفلسطيني رخيص لو
ان الانتصار او الهزيمه حسبتها ماديه بعدد
الذين ي يقتلون او بعدد المؤسسات التي
تدمر لا اعتبرنا هتلر منتصرا لان هتلر قتل
اكثر بكثير مما قتل الاخرون في الحرب
العالميه الثانيه اها لا اعتبرنا
الفرنسيين منتصرين على الشعب الجزائري
قتلوا منه
مليون هل لما نزلنا احنا في ميدان التحرير
كنا ضد شرع الله ولا ضد رئيس مستبد هل لما
نزلنا في ميدان التحرير كنا ضد تطبيق
الشريعه ولا ضد ان تتحول الشريعه الى
الاله مرسي هو اللي يحدد ايه الشريعه وايه
اللي مش الشريعه وهكذا اللي ما بينجز اللي
يشك الحكومه رئيس وزرائها وزير زراعه
ويغفل جميع الكفاءات اللي موجوده ولا يعمل
الا لرؤيه واحده تمكين الاخوان وجماعه
الاخوان اين هي اخوانه الدوله 35 وزير
منهم اربعه اخوان 28 محافظ منهم ثلاثه فقط
من الاخوان كل رؤساء المدن على مستوى مصري
سمهم واحد من الاخوان كل رؤساء القرى
والوحدات المحليه والدارات والوزراء وكل
جهاز الشرطه والجهاز الدبلوماسي كله 192
سفي فيش واحد منهم من الاخوان كل قيادات
الجيش حت حتى حتى الضباط الصح الملازم اول
ليس وج واحد منهم الاخوان اين هي الاخوان
تحدثون
عنها انت تعلم الان ثلثي الجمعيه العموميه
في الامم المتحده اعترفت بالممثل
بالائتلاف ممثلا شرعيا وحيدا
للشعب السوري نعم الا تعتقد الان على بشار
الاسد ان يستحي ويخجل لان حلمه في البقاء
اصبح مثل حلم ابليس بالجنه الرئيس بشار
الاسد ياخذ شرعيته من شعبه نقطه على السطر
انا لا يهمني ل الاسرائيلي ولا الامريكي
ولا العملاء الصغار اللي عم يشتغلوا على
تدمير سوريا بشار الاسد الاسد ياخذ شرعيته
من شعبه بشار الاسد ليس رئيس جمهوريه هو
رمز لوحده سوريا وبقاء سوريا هو اكبر من
رئيس جمهوريه رئيس جمهوريه مثل مثل زين
العابدين بن علي اللي هرب ثاني نهار وقعد
بالسعوديه ولحد الان ما حدا
تونسي انت ناقص تردد اللي قاله هذا
المجنون بمجلس الشعب انت ما بحق لك تحكم
سوريا تحكم العالم حقول كيك انت بتعرفش
يك قتل مين قتل مين الان تسليط الضوء هو
على الرئيس بشار الاسد من اجل ت من اجل
اسقاط سوريا من اجل اسقاط هو دمر سوريا هو
ما دم سوريا هو ما دم اللي دم سوريا هي
العصابات الارهابيه عم تجي من طيب ليش
خليها تدمرها ليش خليه يدمرها وين جيشه
كيف وين جيشه وين جيشه اسمح لي الاتحاد
السوفيتي بقوته وبقدراته لما لما تحالفت
السعوديه وباكستان وامريكا وانشا القاعده
وطالبان ما هزموا الاتحاد السوفيتي
بافغانستان نعم هل شعبه ينتخب على تشريد 7
ملايين سوري على قتل اكثر من 200 ال سوري
على سجن اكثر من مليون سوري على اكثر من
500000 سوري مشردين ياكلون الزباله في في
خارج سوريا ي هل ينتخب بشار الاسد على
تدمير ثلاث ارباع سوريا لك اي شعبه يا
زلمه على مين عم تضحك اخي ما عم نضحك حدا
اسمح لي شوي انا انا انت انت عايش بالدوحه
وحضرته عايش بالمانيا اول امبارح تم تهجير
سكان مخ من اليرموك زوجه اخي من اللي
تهاجروا هلا حاليا بلبنان كيف تهجروا دخل
لا ما ضرب لا ما ضربهم لا لا
لا يا حبيبي دخلوا حبيبي يا
حبيبيي لا يوجد رئيس عنده شرف ويترك وطنه
يتقسم لا يمكن لا يمكن هل هذا الشعب فقد
كرامته الى الدرجه التي تقصفه الطائرات
ويبقى مؤيدا وتقصفه الدبابات ويبقى مؤيدا
وتدخل المخ مخابرات الى مخادع نسائه ويبقى
مؤيدا تقصف جيوشه مساجد المسلمين ويبقى
مؤيدا يدخل على البنات ويدخل على المدارس
ويدخل على المستشفيات ويحرم على صيدلي ان
يصرف حبه دواع هل هذا هو الشعب الذي يؤيد
بشار الاسد قل لي اذا كان الشعب هذا حاله
في البرار والقفار وحاله في المدنيات
وحاله في القرى وحاله في الطبابه وحاله في
كل شيء ماذا بقي من هذا الشعب السوري حتى
يقال ان شعبه يؤيده هل فقد كرامته الشعب
السوري حتى يعتبر ان قصف الطائرات مداعبه
وقصف الدبابات ملاعبه وان هجمات جيشه جيشه
المغولي جيشه التتري جيشه الاسرائيلي يدخل
الى كل مكان باسق الاسلحه بينما يوجد بعض
المقاومين من لديهم بنادق لعنكم الله
جميعا سبعه ملايين في الشارع في القف في
الوديان تحت الشجر يموتون وانت تتحدث عن
ان الشعب السوري يريد بشار وان الشعب
السوري يجب ان يستفتى ببشار وينتخب بشار
وشعبه في يا ابن الاسد يا يا عبيد الاسد
فخر فخر فخر لراسي فخر لراسي لانه بكره
النصره بس انه شافوك بتعرف فليذبح
مثل ما ذبحوا قرايبك مثل الطفل ذبح
قرايبك
الق والله تبون القران والور والحياه
تفبرك المستقبل
والما وتنكرون الحقائق وتكذب على انفسكم
وعلى شعبكم وثم تذهب الى 70 محلا وتقول
انا علوي وادافع عن حرائر العلويات
العلويات يهمونك العلويات من تعرف من
العلويات انت من يدافع عن بشار الاسد يمكن
ان يدافع عن حرائر العلويين طبعا الذين صب
العديد منهم هو وشبيحته هل انت تدافع عن
العلويين ل تضعني في موقع في موقع الشتيمه
انهم اهلي
واك انت تشتم يوميا في
سوريا انت تشتم في جبال العلويين اكثر
اكثر من ما
ي عهد الانتقال السلمي الى الديمقرا ما هو
مستقبل بشار الاسد بعد الاعترافات كي ننهي
البرنامج يجب ان يقتل ويقاوم ويقتل حتى
يهزم وحتى اخر وكر
[تصفيق]
يلجا اليه لا دوله علويه لانه لا علاقه له
بالعلويين ولا ولا وكر ياويه سيموت كما
مات الكلاب من قتل ملايين الناس وهجرهم
وانتقم منهم وحقد عليهم من اعار
الجن الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء
h